así
felicidades ya son expertos en puntos
medios
así que continuemos dije que las curvas
creadas con la construcción de
esculturas de hilos son parábolas pero
como sabemos que eso es verdad en
realidad es un poco difícil demostrarlo
rigurosamente pero podemos conseguir un
poco de intuición en el siguiente
ejercicio tal vez ya hayan visto los
saltos para vuelcos en las gráficas de
las ecuaciones cuadráticas como esta por
ejemplo aquí tengo una curva verde
esa es la gráfica de una función
cuadrática y es una parábola y tengo una
curva sur generada mediante una
escultura con hilo y mi trabajo en este
ejercicio será su trabajo en el
ejercicio el cual va a ser ver si pueden
reposicionar los puntos para que la
curva azul cuadre perfectamente sobre la
curva verde entonces por ejemplo voy a
intentar mover este punto no ser digamos
aquí abajo y este otro punto lo voy a
mover no sé se me ocurre por acá y este
otro por allá
así la curva azul se está acercando pero
observa que no se encuentra exactamente
sobre la curva verde
yo quiero pedirles que lo intenten en el
siguiente ejercicio